you're playing like a [ __ ] game
right game right now now you watch your
sources for that what are the things
that you're talking about everybody
knows that they were individuals who
were identified as talking in
confidential conversations Becton I
don't know what you're talking about
because I don't know what your source is
okay well thank you thank you for your
walk down nonsense Lane hi I'm Matthew
Feeney from Reason TV here to discuss
the Bradley Manning trial I am joined by
Eli Lake national security correspondent
for The Daily Beast in newsweek adam
class felt from courthouse news and
alexa o'brien an independent journalist
covering the bradley manning trial Alexa
died like to begin with you why should
we care about the Bradley Manning trial
Bradley Manning trial is a historic case
it is the largest criminal investigation
ever into a publisher and its source it
has wide ramifications on the First
Amendment there are charges in the
Bradley Manning trial that have never
been used in military law they're not
tied to any kind of federal or punitive
article under the Uniform Code of
Military Justice
one of them's want in publication the
fact that this young soldier has been
charged with aiding the enemy for
essentially leaking information to a
media organization it's also cause for
grave concern amongst the press Eli do
you think it's uh significant is Alexa
does I think it's a significant case
because of the unprecedented wholesale
leak that Bradley Manning enabled it
changed I think the way that we look at
the war on terror it changed how a lot
of people in countries like Tunisia
regarded their government index and it
confirmed a lot of things that were kind
of in the sort of you know everybody
sort of nodded knew about them but you
know we had evidence that you know the
president of Yemen for example was you
know lying to was in Congress I mean he
was in Parliament about American drone
strikes in his country and this case is
significant because I don't think the
military really I think the military in
lot of ways never kind of envisioned
that they would ever have to prosecute
something like this and out of when was
the it is if it really is as
unprecedented as Eli and Alexis I
mentioned when when can you give us a
bit of a background
of these sort of aiding the enemy cases
and when the last time someone like this
was prosecuted well the last time that
the aiding the enemy charge has been
used for a leak to the press was a civil
war era the case of private Henry
VandeWater who leaked a union roster to
a newspaper in Alexandria Virginia that
seems like a quite a different matter
altogether there's a fact record then
what's happening in this case what what
do you think'll XR about the aiding the
enemy charge who what enemy was actually
aided in this case well according to the
bill of particulars there are two
enemies al Qaeda and al Qaeda of the
Arabian Peninsula there was a classified
enemy that we only knew as Bates number
such and such debates number such and
such but that actually was withdrawn by
the prosecution a late right before they
closed their case sure but do do you
think it isn't I mean it all of Isis
aiding the enemy it's a little bit of a
complicated story but I think Julian
Assange at one point did try to work
with the US government to redact
elements of it the u.s. government
rejected that offer a version of
WikiLeaks was published with actual
names of individuals who had
confidential conversations with US
diplomats that is something akin to
publishing the kind of confidential
informant list of a police department
and so even if you didn't give it
directly to the Mafia or you didn't give
it directly the criminal element they
can read it just like everybody else and
in that sense we know that there were
enormous efforts to try to get certain
people out of harm's way there were
public statements from some of some
groups particularly in Lebanon of people
who would talk to various diplomats and
it caused a lot of problems so I think
people who wanted to help the United
States in dangerous places that said it
also disclosed lots of things I think
the United the American people had a
right to know about the nature of the
war in the nature of these relationships
and it disclosed lots of things that
people of Tunisia and Yemen and Egypt
these things know about their own
government disclosure of those of those
names I mean it's been said that none of
them have come into harm's way I think
that's one way it's an important fact
for understanding yes I'm so much
it's actually factually not true if you
look at what WikiLeaks released these
are the the media partners especially
with regards to Cablegate it was the
most control release of the manning
documents and WikiLeaks didn't release
anything that wasn't similarly released
by their media partners with regards to
Cablegate in terms of the persons at
risk group that was disbanded within
months it formally it was formally
meeting and then within months had
stopped formally meeting and met
informally in terms of the evidence
presented in discovery and and this
person will come up in the sentencing
but there are three classified damage
assessments one of them is the State
Department and there is no harm no
actual harm why don't we so I've saw the
cables myself these intelligence reports
they say so-and-so living in such a town
you know met with the military and there
were there were other tranches besides
Cablegate when you name those people if
you cover a war access to cable gate on
the SIP de system there was no password
protection on sip this okay it's
relevant it's very low level
intelligence it doesn't contain humans
in it there are cables of people in
places like Azerbaijan meeting with US
diplomats talking about illicit Iranian
activities I made it into the Super's
presented in the trial not a speculative
analysis from away from the court I'm
not telling you a speculative analysis I
have eyes to read I read the cables I
know I cover Wars I cover these people a
lot when you put somebody out there in a
confidential meeting in a situation in a
country like Azerbaijan Lebanon
Afghanistan what-have-you and when you
do that you are putting that person at
risk which is why the State Department
and other elements of the US government
had to in some cases actually get people
out of harm's way
so what you can say whatever you want
it's not a it's not as clear a cut case
and I acknowledge that there was public
benefit to a lot of these things as well
but to sit here and just say that there
was no impact or whatsoever there's a
reason why those things I don't know how
I'm stating no but what I'm stating Eli
isn't just simply a my my opinion on it
which is what you're Steve no I'm not
eloping I'm stating what
coming out of the court record which is
actually considered to be fact in terms
of the process of reasoning what I don't
know why the prosecution decided to
present facts as they did or not present
facts as they did
I'm also presenting you facts there were
lots of efforts by the US government to
get people out of harm's way
there were terrorist groups that
announced that they were going to be
going through these to find who
informers were and I've talked to people
who say you know so it's you know you
can say you can say what everyone I'm
saying when you have that massive a data
dump
there's no it's not it's not always
going to be you know roses and one thing
about this this in terms of the term
data dump as well Manning is a product
of the information age he grew up with
social media he grew up with an
accessibility to information with Google
I mean he's very much a child of that
generation so to look at his leaks one
has to also understand that they're
completely proportional to the
information age and you know as yokai
benkler testified in court last week
with regards to large data dumps which
is what the prosecution said you know
yokai benkler talked about the fact that
insight can be gleaned from these large
data sets that they provide beyond just
simply confirmation and revelation of a
small set of documents they actually
they actually provide insight that you
couldn't glean let me just talk about a
kind of unrelated what what could have
been called a data table but was not
performed by WikiLeaks the federal pacer
database when it first came into
existence and this is an on the under
explored parallel I think when it first
came into existence there sprang up a
website called who's a rat and because
and that website came into existence
because the names of government sources
became exposed in a completely vetted
and official database it's a database
that every US journalists use and is
thankful for its existence had the very
same issues of the does the benefit of
enriching the public record outweigh the
potential risks of disclosure now that's
not a free well we have a in our court
system when someone rats in a
criminal case we you know there are
classified courtrooms but that was worth
they testify in open court putting all
their names in the suit so they are
aware of the risk to a certain extent
when they testify in court when an
informant talks to somebody in the US
Embassy or in the Iraq war Afghanistan
war you know town elder meets with you
know US intelligence analyst or
something like that there is an
expectation in fact there's a great
expectations I know because I deal with
confidential sources that you know their
names will not appear in public oh
absolutely those names did appear in
public it caused damage to those
individuals now well see I think this
period well know what it caused it is is
potential damage I mean we have guys
splitting hairs very vague and sloppy
about it I mean this is a very serious
trial in many cases it's historic so
most like the Scopes trial because we're
talking about a generational shift with
in terms of who has the right to
intervene is important role I also want
to ask them each of you I suppose if in
the age of the internet if the argument
is going to be well terrorists could
have accessed this information doesn't
that isn't it isn't that a sort of weak
standard to set considering that no it's
not and I'm sorry I just
I'd like have very little patience for
its you're talking about relationships
and conversations that the person
expects anonymity and confidentiality on
when you when you when you rip that away
whether you did it for good reasons or
bad reasons and whether you whether that
results in the murder of the individual
or just that individual having to change
his phone number or whatever I think
that that you have to count that as part
of the harm I'm not one of these people
who says that that's the reason Bradley
Manning is a bad person I think it's a
very complicated case and in the end I
think he should get leniency because I
think in the end this isn't a product of
excessive secrecy from the government
having these excessive relationships
when you expose that information we know
more about what our government is doing
we know more about the actual war and so
I think that there's a lot of public
benefit as well so I'm trying to come in
but I just I never have been persuaded
that you could say that there was no
harm or that you know
it hasn't been proven and I just I
didn't under and I don't quite
understand why Bradley Manning's
defenders have tried to sort of stick to
this case as if none of this is a big
deal if you ever covered in a warzone
you know what it's like to get that kind
of information and when you get some
into it to trust you and then to have
that trust ripped away
Henry's is that the cables were marked
sip dis which means they were widely
distributed amongst US government
employees and federal contractors
firstly and in terms of that's the
Bradley Manning supporters like okay you
know that's the sort of assumption that
you're making I'm talking about the
facts in the case as presented in the
court record and I'm relaying those
facts now if we want to talk about
misinformation and we want to talk about
speculation we can talk about US
government statements that Manning was
harming other people that Manning had
was that his leaks were a threat to
national security not merely
embarrassing the rhetoric coming out of
the White House calling him guilty
before trial calling you know WikiLeaks
and Bradley Manning criminals all of the
different aspects of the interagency
process that were honed in on WikiLeaks
as well as the accused Bradley Manning I
think is even more important story than
speculative or hypothetical harm to
people that was drummed up in the press
and led to people calling for his
execution that to me seems completely
unreasonable and I think also a bit
unjust one thing that I would say thank
you for your adjectives
one thing I would say is from any side
of this it should be grounded in fact
and I mean to say conclusively fact
occurred that a that harm occurred when
we aren't there yet and we have a large
body of evidence saying that the harm
was not anywhere near as cracked up to
be
I think rather than having these kind of
conclusive well can no harm occurred
harm occurred I think that we need to
wait for the facts to come in this case
has always been about are the risks of
disclosure outweighed by the like right
no I agree it's not an either/or I think
it's somebody at some
I just think that and more this this
case is also about transparency and
about whether or not this individual can
get a fair trial what is actually
happening in the courtroom you know so
many people will make commentary on this
case and they are not privy not through
no fault of their own because there was
no public docket so so many people are
misinformed about the actualities in the
courtroom that I think are really
actually more informative to public
debate about the value of these
disclosures and where we are as a nation
what age we live in and where those
boundaries are between as you had you
know asked earlier state secrecy and the
First Amendment what you've just a quick
question I but you presumably do believe
that there is a line that that the state
does have the right to some secrets what
what do you think that line should be
and what the should the punishment be
for crossing it by you disclosing
classified information well to answer
your first question about where that
line should be I think that when we
oftentimes talk about this question the
line is already assumed to be the
national security state and the the
intelligence you know sector but for me
state secrecy includes unlimited private
donations to camp you know to to
candidates I think that's the kind of
state secrecy that's also very dangerous
in addition to national security because
what it does is it essentially erodes
the fundamental checks and balances that
create just and stable governance
now clearly governments and states need
to have secrets chase Medora talks about
the fact that if you look at you know
how much the u.s. classifies in a year
it's one it's essentially you know what
manning leaked was 1% of what the US
government classifies in a year if the
US government actually classified
recipes out high if the US government
actually classified less you know and
really kept a hold of what was genuinely
top you know top secret or secret and
what was genuinely just simply you know
the mistake of a you know original
classification authority I think they'd
have a better time handling that
information in the information age you
were asking the limits of acceptable
limits of state secrecy and it's really
interesting I mean really Monday
answer would be I think it's pretty well
outlined in several executive orders
what what a what's something we could
agree upon the vulnerabilities of
systems intelligence sources and methods
these are fairly non-controversial
things do you think sources and methods
are a problem then when you have sources
revealed in these cables there are
resources and methods in septic Able's
well as I'm saying literally human
sources were in the intelligence
database and their name they were named
and identified and there were also in
Cablegate what's your source for that
the freakin documents I remember better
so you're reviewing the documents and
you see the sources in it so this is
your opinion on whether or not their
sources and methods in there I have no
idea really what you're saying I know it
was his name's the guy who met with the
other guy who got front of me right now
I read about this like three years ago
I'm telling you and it was widely cited
you can find out what your source is how
am I supposed to value whether or not
personally in the documents you're
playing like a game right now matter you
want your sources for that what are the
things that you're talking about
everybody knows that they were
individuals who were identified as
talking in confidential conversations
Matson I don't know what you're talking
about because I don't know what your
source is well thank you thank you for
your walk down nonsense name I think
actually your nonsense because you don't
have a source to bring it to I think
something where we can kind of get a
more productive discussion of this is
named individuals who had confidential
conversations with us official we say no
you have no evidence of that what you're
saying is that let me finish my sentence
okay I am NOT on the Jerry Springer Show
first of all there is actually public
reporting that people who were contacted
by the State Department who were thought
to be on these persons at risk group
this matrix that they made up who are
like you know what I don't even know why
you're calling me in terms of whether or
not there were named sources clearly
there was a mitigation team and that
they handled
whatever it is that they needed to
the reality of it and the original
question that you asked is was there any
actual harm and that there wasn't I mean
from the pre trial record there wasn't
well can I can I let me just in plain
English because I mean in an odd way I
find myself often arguing have the
benefits of WikiLeaks you have a basic
harm that when governments even have
confidential diplomatic conversations
with people such as mayor de Gahan you
know discussing what the Israeli
strategy for stopping the Iranian
nuclear program with Nick burns is one
cable I remember writing about there's
an expectation from these governments
that these conversations would not be
public because people are going to say
things in private now does that mean
that therefore it should it shouldn't
have been Declassified I think it's a
case-by-case issue but I think there's
clearly harm in that everybody says this
now the u.s. does not have the same
level of trust that it can hold secrets
the way that it did before so people are
not with that that limits in some ways
diplomas to jump off that thing and
harms US diplomatic there was not a very
exotic hacking tool that Bradley Manning
used to get this data he downloaded a
piece of freeware and he had
unprecedented access I've spoken to
diplomats who one diplomat told me she
read more cables and this is a diplomat
who has served decades in the Foreign
Service
she read more cables from the WikiLeaks
disclosure than she had in her entire
career and this is from a 22 year old at
the time intelligence we should say you
accept that for diplomacy to function in
a good way that diplomats need to be
able to communicate with one another
with assume confidentiality would you
agree the base for allowing people to be
you know open about their thoughts
before coming to any kind of conclusion
I mean I think that's absolutely
completely appropriate so the thing is
it's a worthwhile argument to make that
Eli was hinting at earlier that if you
harm the United States ability to
conduct diplomacy that harms been done
well listen well let's talk about like
who is the who is the actor who should
be attributed the responsibility firstly
if we look at the you know public
reporting the government's own studies
over-classification even properly
trained classification authorities
misclassify do you remember the
percentage point something north of
sixty percent yes sixty-four percent I
think is what it is
the other issue here is in terms of
public diplomacy is within this database
the SIP dis database it should not have
contained anything that would have
caused any kind of great
you know damage to bilateral
relationships I'm gonna say okay so one
I Greece we have way too many secrets
there's huge parts of the government
that are secrets and I'm against it and
I like unauthorized disclosures and
leaks and I don't like the crackdown on
leakers and I'm very much on the
libertarian side of his I've written
plenty of times even for this
publication so I'm generally very
sympathetic to all those arguments but
getting into the percentage of stuff you
have to go like look at the contents of
it these cables disclosed things that
were incredibly damaging to specific
relationships and in that respect you
have to ask yourself well maybe it's
worth it like I I I'm of the view that
it's kind of extraordinary that the
president of Yemen can allow the United
States to conduct drone warfare in his
country and lie about it to his own fake
Parliament okay but the reality is if
you talk to people who did diplomacy in
Yemen that's the only way they could be
allowed to do it because of the peculiar
era T's of Yemen in this period so I'm
not saying that in I'm not I think in
the end probably is good that we know
exactly these the true nature of these
relationships okay or for example that
the king of Saudi Arabia the crown
prince of Saudi Arabia rather said that
you know Iran was a snake and you had to
cut off the head and so forth but that
also kind of causes harm to our ally in
Saudi Arabia because and and and one and
there have been some people I'm just
saying I wanted I want to respond to
this two points the first is that Jewish
I was recently released from prison and
you know the WikiLeaks release showed
that essentially he was reporting the
fact that US was cluster bombing in
Yemen here is a journalist speaking
about the First Amendment a Yemeni
Journal journalist who Obama
specifically requested he be kept in
prison
even after Amnesty International after
the WikiLeaks release called for his
release because clearly he was printing
the truth you know I'll even go back you
know reuters reported in January 2011
that State Department officials were
playing up harm if they were playing a
parm in front of Congress in order to
bolster a prosecution of not only Julian
Assange but also of WikiLeaks and so
clearly there is this overhyped rhetoric
and one of the values of having a trial
is we get to see what are the facts what
is actually happening because without
the truth we can't really make proper
judgments about what we should do what's
appropriate and what isn't appropriate
well let me just go back I just want to
ask you a question I mean you were
talking about the Yemeni cable cable as
an example of harm are you do you
believe that that was one that shouldn't
become public I told you I think there
was value acqua see the president of
Yemen sure sure the world is a little
bit more complicated and if you believe
that you needed to have the secrecy in
order to conduct this action in Yemen
and the only one who was allowed to know
about it is like you know the head of
the Yemeni security services and the
president of Yemen and a few people
there okay and everything else was going
to be hushed up and they were gonna lie
to their own public if we were gonna lie
to our public now
I'm not I'm against I'm for sunshine I
think it's good that we know all the
facts we know that Mike my question is
specifically regarding this cable where
does a balance tip for you but it's it's
not about I'm not I'm not a policymaker
I'm a journalist I'm just saying that if
you don't recognize that there is a
downside I suppose to the relationship I
the government can define as harm who
said they don't recognize there's a
downside there isn't a bilateral that's
a point that I've accepted I think as I
said I would agree I'm glad that we know
the truth about that and I think it
makes us more informed and I think that
the US should I think all the secrecy is
that grounds it to a very more
productive discussion where does the
line exists and where should it exist
I interviewed four retired foreign
service officers and talk to them
broadly about the concept of open
diplomacy and that was what manning
professed when when he leaked this the
data in the internet chats he said that
he was inspired by Woodrow Wilson's Open
diplomacy ideals now I asked diplomats
about that and you know fully expecting
that they'd say oh you can't do that
with cables don't don't be absurd and
what I found was very diverse answers
some people felt that cables should not
be released under any circumstances and
some said this is how an official
database could work this is how the
government could actually get behind a
public repository of cables so I think
once we ground the discussion into the
nitty-gritty of it in if that's the case
when can it be released what can be
released then we can have a productive
then we can move forward um I would just
be interested to hear all the
participants opinions on Bradley
Manning's future the trial is still
ongoing sentencing is still to happen
Eli earlier you mentioned that you think
he deserves some leniency what what do
you think would be an appropriate
punishment for what Bradley Manning if
he's found I might well like kind of
getting into that as a journalist I
don't think he should be put away for
the rest of his life but that said both
eyes are open and I think that there are
instances of harm that we've kind of
discussed earlier as well and I think
you know as you pointed out Alexa he
acknowledged that he he he acknowledged
that harm in his own in his own plea and
I think that that's probably about you
know where it is at this point please I
think part of what brought this trial
astray is the decision to treat this
rather than a case of civil disobedience
in the case of a traitor and a spy the
tree using the 100 year old statute the
Espionage Act originally designed to
prosecute pacifists during World War one
who were getting the way of the war
effort or exhuming this 150 year old
interpretation of the aiding the enemy
statute to set this very troubling
precedent Alexa what do you think
the verdict is likely to be or what the
sentences are likely to be and what do
you think separately he deserves I think
that um judge Lindh will there's a very
good possibility she'll find him guilty
of aiding the enemy and I also think
that she will find him guilty of some of
the greater offenses for the espionage I
think that Bradley Manning will be
sentenced for a very put away for a very
very long time I don't think that he
should get more than a couple of years
maybe even time served either what are
your thoughts one of the things that was
really eye-opening I think is when we
learned about how he was treated in the
interim he was on the suicide watch
which was a form of almost it seemed
like torture a psychological torture
where he couldn't sleep
he was in this room and constantly
checking up and kind of fur its own good
it was out of Clockwork Orange I'm not
yeah that's sort of what it was like I
mean it was it was extraordinary to kind
of read that despite him staying in an 8
by 6 cell 23 hours a day or more the
ruling was that there was no solitary
confinement I mean that's part of the
findings of fact and that is that says
something about the how widely the
practice of isolation is in America in
American prisons and that it's not even
recognized as such in a case as in this
one where someone is spending more at
least if not more than 23 hours a day in
an 8 by 6 foot cell we've spoken a
little bit about the actual effects of
the the leaks on American diplomacy and
policy but I suppose I would be very
interested ask Li what you think the
actual foreign policy implications are
especially in respect to did this snow
bowl the Arab Spring or is that
exaggerated what do you think the actual
effects have been internationally it's
hard to say that it is a direct cause
and effect but we do know that at least
in the case of Tunisia where it it
started off a lot of the organizers
cited WikiLeaks cables and the
corruption specifically the Ben Ali
family as one of the factors that sort
of led to this popular outrage and it is
outrageous and the United States have
these had these kind of you know they
were imperfect I've done
they were they were there were
problematic relationships with
dictatorships and those dictatorships
relied on secrecy and we became partners
in that kind of secrecy in lying to
those public public and we held those
secrets and those secrets were contained
in those cables which is why despite the
designation they were very significant
that's my point is that you know and and
like I there's way too much over
classification and stuff and I I would
just I would say that Bradley Manning
would have done himself think more
favors if instead of making the sort of
determination I'm going to release
things of this classification level if
he would have said these 30 cables show
and it were or if that had that had
happened and instead of it being as I
said the kind of wholesale like
everything in this classification was at
then I think I think I think it would
have been a much cleaner case that he
was a whistleblower and and an active
civil experience well I I agree that it
would have been a cleaner case of
whistleblowing
I think that qualifies as civil
disobedience either way some of his
leaks were classic whistleblowing
I mean the the Baghdad airstrike video
that would be entitled collateral murder
and there are things that kind of expand
upon the concept and take us into our
unchartered territory of is this broad
category of data can we learn more from
it one example that you highbanker use
was with the Afghanistan excuse me the
Iraq war logs the benefit of the mass
leak without the mass leak of that
entire cig acts the public would not
have had the data to contest official
casualty counts you don't get that from
smoking gun documents but if you think
about the fact that Julian Assange as
editor-in-chief of WikiLeaks sent a
letter to Harold Koh at the State
Department the legal adviser of the
State Department and asked specifically
you know is there anything that needs to
be pulled from these that is a direct
quorum to United States the fact that
the State Department didn't take him up
on that offer so to speak and work with
WikiLeaks to filter out I think speaks
volumes to essentially their
irresponsibility if there was
fact something in that disclosure that
actually you know hypothetically could
cause damage the other thing too is when
the State Department was briefing
Congress right when the leaks were
coming out and they had already had six
months because the Defense Intelligence
Agency information review task force
they knew what was it what was coming
out they knew which documents Manning
had their review gates roto senator
Levin there were essentially no sources
methods in this release it didn't mean
that it wouldn't harm national security
but national security broadly defined
economic interests political interests
not specifically intelligence assets the
other thing too is when those State
Department officials spoke to Congress
an anonymous congressional aide two of
them told Reuters that the State
Department played up that damage to
bolster their prosecution so those are
all those other factors that need to be
put into this discussion around these
leaks because we've had enough of the
rhetoric of you know hyperbolic rhetoric
of you know fear fear fear what we need
to do as a nation I think and as a press
it's helped the public have an informed
discussion about the reality of these
leaks and we need to ground that
discussion in fact the the potential
harm caused by the leaks of the
Guantanamo detainee profiles the
government has charged what is it five
five detainee profiles as representative
for the potential harm which detainees
we don't know that's a secret but we
have a hint of them and the hint is and
this is based on public by public
reporting of the defense witness it
looks like it might be the Tipton's
three the UK residents who were released
not charged with anything and who have
subsequently made anti Guantanamo Bay
documentaries what's interesting is the
u.s. government considers them
terrorists recidivists because of these
documentary films what do you think
Bradley Manning's demeanor is do you how
do you think he feels about his
potential sentence what I've seen is a
young man grow up in a courtroom I mean
when we first saw Bradley Manning he had
very pink skin
he looked very young and he was very
young and now he's 25 years old his jaw
is sharper he is he's a very methodical
person on the stand and he's also very
reserved he only speaks of course when
spoken to
he's a very earnest character I mean
it's his earnestness comes off as very
naive when you first hear him at least
that's my impression but as you continue
to listen to him there's this kind of
old-fashioned common sense that comes
through that's um it's quite endearing
ego three of you I'd like to ask what
you think the biggest takeaway from this
the Bradley Manning cases you learn a
lot more from the of the trial if you
look at it in terms of what we know
about the way our social institutions
function we should be having a
discussion about open diplomacy we
should be having discussions about the
contents of the leaks to a much higher
extent you know for us we have too many
secrets the secret bureaucracy is way
too big we should probably demand more a
lot more transparency and we should have
a serious I mean sort of a serious
discussion about what are the secrets
that are worth protecting and then we
have to ask ourselves is this country as
a superpower capable of having
diplomatic relations and having allies
that rely on massive secrecy themselves
from their own population about the very
nature of that relationship can you have
the kind of relationship that we had for
years with Hosny Mubarak in Egypt or in
Pakistan where we were silent about all
the many things that we did that the
Pakistani said we we never would do and
that hypocrisy was exposed by WikiLeaks
that is a good thing that it's exposed
in my view it's good thing for probably
the people living in those countries and
it's a good thing for us but going
forward it's gonna be very I think it's
gonna it's next to impossible to try to
do the diplomacy that relied on their
secrets and in many ways there's lies
going forward Aleksei your final force I
think that there will be more bradley
manning's i think it's inevitable
because of the age that we live in and I
think in a certain way we're going
through a type of Reformation it's a
Reformation for the secular age of
information and we're in the middle of
it and even within the press pool you
can see that Reformation and that
melding between experience like the AP
guy who's been around forever and you
know people like me who have just come
to this and have been providing you know
sort of asymmetric you know websites
with all the documents for the case and
there's been a kind of an ongoing a
developing conversation that we've
experienced and I think that the
established press as well as this you
know newer form of digital journalism or
journalism is happening right now and
it's a very exciting time it's also a
very scary time when we think about the
NSA and what the NSA is doing with
technology so we're living in very
interesting times
my thanks to Eli Lake Adam class felt
like so Brian from Reason TV I'm Matthew
Feeney